it is one of those companies where  there's lots of of improv going on I'm  guessing there's lots of improv going on  which you both enjoyed yeah I mean any  especially she enjoys when I like insult  her  it's true yeah you're really good at it  she said very easy to insult I mean I  don't know it's just something about  your sincerity or something you know  what I'm not gonna argue it that I know  my favorite is when you called me an  animatronic [ __ ] on that day you  really look like you called me a big 2/3  Russell Crowe story rebels like Annie  called me a big tater isochronous  what did I make up you did  I like are you watching me from there  really  [Music]  you